my [ __ ] rear I'm holding on to smash
[Music]
walk about two bamboo me joshing hasten
today we are joined by the kick-ass man
himself Paul Rudd's how you doing I'm
all right how's it going good good and
the kick-ass Marvel honey herself
Anjali Lily thank you now my major
question I took away from this was what
would a clueless and ant-man crossover
that like oh so I feel like it could
happen anything can happen in this
franchise ant-man and Cher kind of Ming
right homies you're gonna roll with them
yeah but there was there a point when
you're filming this when you lie I think
they may have taken this a bit too far
cuz this is her with the hilarious bits
and it's like whoa I never saw that
coming oh yeah I think we were all kind
of into the challenge of going too far
with some things the past Hello Kitty my
man yeah come on how big is that gonna
be in Japan when it opens out to be
furring Hello Kitty's not use I want
that to be true I want to get off a
plane and have people just start
chucking hands dispensers that means
enormous ones yeah but there were many
conversations happening before we shot
the scene where I really feel as if
Michelle Pfeiffer has somehow possessed
me in a way well I bet you never fought
in your whole career you were gonna have
Michelle Pfeiffer possess yay I feel
like she has my whole life
every time I lounge on the top of a
piano just prance around my apartment in
a leather cat suit I mean that's a lot
of talcum powder right there isn't there
and not enough no we're gonna play a
game you call Marvel mashup and there's
some songs on these cards all right and
then the name of a fellow Marvel
Universe character you have to
impersonate the press on the card have
to guess who it is
you can even sing it or you can say it
you're going to realize how much of a
bad student I am when it comes to
marbles I bet I won't even know the
songs oh you will that power ballads
it's the eye of the dog he's really
raspy is the thrill of the fight rising
up to the big big ball chin bounce ball
second rising up to the challenge of our
rival fibro okay great a little eyebrow
and the last known survivor stalks his
prey
nice right somewhere around there finals
you killed Ted money I'm holding on to
smash the diction on that was incredible
I trying to get in holding out for a
hero
and it's very light intense muscular
action right yeah so I'm guessing you're
the Hulk yeah
boom diving I think I might be the only
person on earth who hasn't seen greatest
showmen whoa you you looked genuinely I
assure you I be shocked yeah because
people love the yeah it's great I saw
the woman sing it on the Oscars mm-hmm
nails wasn't spice guy see it how do you
know what I got emails to return to
trash yeah who's got time to go hey
Louie a PT Barnum is that who it is
about
you
[Music]